- This is the practise recording
for my Eurostar keynote.
I'm gonna try and give you
the full keynote experience
'cause Eurostar asked us to
pick a track that we'll use
for the intro and the walk on.
So I'm gonna play that.
Then I'll dive into the
talk so you get the full
immersive stadium type experience.
(uptempo rock music)
Alright. (laughs)
So, that was The Trooper.
That was Iron Maiden's, The Trooper.
I quite like it.
I mean Eurostar want us the pick a song
so clearly there has to be a message.
But the reason why I picked it is that
there's a common phrase
associated with warfare which
is "your plan does not survive
contact with the enemy".
And there's couple of lessons
you could draw from that
but the lesson I draw from that
is we really want our plans to be simple
to understand and implement.
'Cause it's not gonna stand
up to contact with the enemy
we have to be able to flex around them.
So the more complicated the plan is,
the more interdependent it is,
the more over complicated stuff is
the less we are gonna be able to flex fast
when something changes.
The other thing is if
it's not gonna survive
contact with the enemy,
we need to know what the end objective is
or multiple end objectives
so that we can try
and achieve them.
And we might even want to
know what we're gonna do
after we achieve an end objective
because if we can't even
achieve those objectives
we might be able to think of
new ways that we might be able
to build on it to achieve
the ultimate things
we gonna do afterwards.
So we've got a chain.
The Trooper is essentially
about the person on the ground
the soldier that's in there
and doing the fighting,
doing the job.
And what I think is
important there particularly
for testers is that that person
is drilled into them
the skill set that they need to handle
that environment that they're going in to.
In order to be able to flex,
in order to even to be able
to do the job that they're supposed to do,
they have to know basic
skills or understanding there.
And we don't just throw
people on the battlefield
and expect them to
survive, cause they won't.
And then if we expect them
to adapt to circumstances,
they have to be able to handle things.
Even if you were just
thrown into a battlefield,
you've been given 15 minutes
beforehand you're taught
how to shoot a gun.
You know the basics,
you then have to rely
on your common sense.
You have to observe what
other people are doing.
You have to make this
work in order to survive.
Now, I have the concern that in testing
we over complicate testing right?
I think in the industry
there's a very big temptation
to make it seem really complicated.
I mean if you look at
some of the definitions
that are out there for testing,
some of them are so convoluted,
and they change.
This is why I find
interested about definitions.
I mean if you ever tried to
write your own definition,
it's hard.
But I think it's an
exercise that's worth doing.
It's a very important exercise
to try and define testing.
To get in your head what this thing
that you're working with is.
We have the issue that if
we don't make something
that is over complicated.
Then when you write your own definition
is gonna come out with
something over complicated
'cause you're gonna think
well it doesn't cover
everything that I do.
Well that makes it look
too easy, that makes that
I've over simplified it.
I've over simplified
it because your writing
a definition for yourself
and you know how complicated
and rich this is.
Its a temptation to put all
that in your definition.
But if we then make it public,
there is a temptation that
well then people look at it
and go well this is too easy,
this is something that we
can easily under value.
You can go and train yourself
as a tester and come out
as a certified tester in three days.
So this we can just get
junior people to do this
there's nothing important here.
You don't need 15 years
experience in order to do this.
Then there's a danger in
the testing world we might
get paid even less.
So since we already
get paid even less than
everyone else we'll get...
There's a real danger that
we get and paid even less,
and we don't want that.
We don't want it to get
too simple and too easy
therefore we try to cram everything in
Then it's over complicated and that's bad.
So when I was thinking about this,
I thought right, what I will
do, I will create an example.
I'll create an example
definition of software testing
is a process whereby we use
a software system deployed
in multiple configurations via its GUI API
and all exposed interfaces
to gather information about
its behaviour, flaws and impact
on the user and stakeholder
needs and requirements;
for the purpose of evaluating
the quality and fitness
for purpose in specific
operational environments
and conditions.
Right, 'cause I'm trying
to cram in everything.
I didn't even try hard
This was me looking at
going how would I describe
this if I want to cover
GUI testing API testing,
the different basic feedback,
looking at behaviour,
impact, all of this stuff.
How can I put this in?
So it's an over complicated definition.
Now I read that out,
I don't remember what it was.
I wrote it,
I don't remember what it
really covers or stands for.
It's over complicated.
The thing is,
even having one of those definitions,
we wouldn't stop there.
Because we want to continually
refine our definition.
We want to simplify it
because it's too big.
But then we want to over
complicate it again.
So we delete sections,
we'll change it over time.
Now what's interesting
is that we're doing this
because we're changing it
based on our understanding
as it evolves overtime.
We're also doing it because
we're communicating right?
Now when you're communicate
we have a deep structure.
We have a model, a very complicated model
of what we're trying to communicate,
but we have to make it a very
simple communication process
in order to communicate
to different people.
And different people
understand different things
so we communicate in different ways.
But this is a communication it
isn't what testing is right?
'Cause testing itself
probably hasn't changed right?
The essence of testing
probably hasn't changed
over the years.
So the definition of testing
if it was a description
of an absolute,
wouldn't have changed over the years.
So we're describing a relationship.
Now I thought, since we over
complicate and there's a danger
in over complicating.
I would look at how
other complicated fields
describe themselves like physics.
Physics is complicated.
So I looked in a dictionary,
I thought I could go down stairs,
get the dictionary
but it was too far away
so what I'm gonna do,
I'm just gonna look for
the Google dictionary.
'Cause Google has a dictionary built in,
I will ask that for the definition.
And then I get the notion
of physics, what is physics?
Physics is the branch of science concerned
with the nature and properties
of matter and energy.
Whoo!
And then it even says the
subject matter includes,
now what I would prefer almost,
is includes such things as,
mechanics, heat, light,
structure of atoms, etc.
'cause then it's open ended.
If we have open ended definitions
we can make them really small.
But this, I imagine that
physics covers more than
mechanics, heat, light, radiation,
structure of atoms, stuff like that.
But they've limited it there,
so people probably argue
over that definition
but you stick etc. in and
you make it open world
but bigger it's a little
bit easier to communicate
to people without arguments.
Now in dictionaries there
is very often a derivation
which is important right?
When we look at software testing,
what is a derivation of software testing?
We've taken things from math,
graph theory, Set theory
decision theory, probability theory,
we use sampling processes when
we're coming up with tests.
And particularly Set theory,
leads on to boundary analysis
and equivalence partitioning.
All this stuff is from math
but we don't have,ver often
the derivation of where
we've taken things in software testing.
So we lack something in our definitions.
Which means that we have to
cram it all into our definition
rather than delegate off to someone else
'cause we're an expansive
industry that brings thing in.
I thought well there's
other complicated things
like rocket science.
Rocket science is pretty complicated.
It must have a really
complicated definition.
So I asked Google and Google said
well its something really
very difficult to understand.
You know that's not
really that doesn't really
explain things.
So we are allowed to have
definitions that describe things
in ways that make you
think, that force you
to think about things.
And I thought well I'm really interested
in software testing.
So Google, what is software testing?
And Google doesn't know.
Google doesn't know what
software testing is.
Doesn't have a definition
of it in its dictionary.
I'm sure Google has a software process
and knows what software testing is.
But Google dictionary
doesn't have a definition.
That's saying to me, search the web.
They have no definition, search the web.
Which means we have no choice,
and we are essentially having
to make this up for ourselves.
'Cause if we search the
web what we're seeing,
we're seeing the stuff that other people
have made up for their selves.
Now we can be reliant on what they think
or we can make this up ourselves.
And then I thought you know,
if I was to abstract this
and you think what
exactly is more important?
Is it imagineedfustication?
Or is it working with a good
imagineedfusticator right?
In the real world,
when you've got something that
needs imagineedfusticating.
Do you need to know what that is?
Or do you need to know
someone who can do it?
Is it the definition
of imagineedfusticating
that is important?
Or is it someone who can
actually implement it
and do imagineedfusting like
a good imagineedfusticator.
Now I imagine 'cause I don't know that
what you're thinking is what
is imagineedfusticating?
So I made it up.
Right, it's important that
we learn, we get in the habit
of making things up.
It's a useful discipline.
Make up your own techniques,
make up your own definitions.
Make up your own words!
Make up your own concepts.
Now if you're very lucky,
some of those concepts will
get taken up by other people
and you become famous and well paid.
And you'll be associated with the concept.
No one is going to pick
imagineedfusticating.
But I called it the art of
getting exactly what you need
when you need it.
Now I would rather work with
a good imagineedfusticator,
someone who knows exactly what I need
and knows how exactly to get
it exactly when I need it.
Rather than knowing that's
what imagineedfusticating is.
I want someone to implement that for me.
Most of us in whatever industry we're in
are in that position.
We are trying to get exactly
what someone else needs
when they need 'cause that's
what makes us valuable.
So software testing is
the art of getting exactly
what someone needs associated
with software testing
when they need it.
And that's gonna be contextual.
That's gonna be dependent on
the person we're working with.
So if we assume that we know
nothing about software testing,
'cause there's no definitions,
we have to search the web.
How would we go about working
from first principles?
'Cause we are either going to
be reliant on somebody else
or are we going to make this up.
So I'm going to take a worked example.
Here is an application.
Now this is an application
I, Alan Richardson,
have written and you
can find it on GitHub.
It's a simple CRUD application
that manages books and authors
and there's drop down menus on the top.
It links to go and its
a very simple web app.
I have to test this.
Now assuming that I don't
know that I developed it,
I'm just working from first principles.
How do I test this?
But if I don't know what testing is,
how can I do that right?
Now really I don't want
anyone that I don't know
how to test it right?
'Cause I'm trying to bluff it.
There's a book by Edgar
Rice Burroughs it's called
The Efficiency Expert, Pulp
novel set in The Depression,
guy can't get any work.
He goes in to a factory asking for jobs,
can't get any work 'cause
we've got all the people
low skilled people that
can do all this job
and sees someone else with a clipboard
and goes,"What does he do?"
He's an efficiency expert,
he's helping us make more efficient.
So the guy goes around the
corner at the 2nd hand book shop
finds a manual like how to
be an efficiency expert.
Starts reading that and then goes in knows
enough information to
convince someone to give him
a job as an efficiency expert.
So as long as he stays a couple
pages ahead of everyone else
he can get well paid.
Because it's a Pulp novel,
it eventually degrades
into fights and romance
but the point here being
that we can bluff it.
We can learn stuff on the fly
and go ahead and do it.
We don't necessarily need
to know how to start,
common sense, a lot of
stuff is common sense.
Now there are nuances that we will learn
over time and experience.
But we can start with something simple.
So I'm going to gonna go round the corner
and find a 2nd hand book shop
and find out what is software testing.
Now that's essentially what
we're doing on the web.
So this is not the text from a web site,
it's a text that you
might see on a web site
and it's representative
of the kind of things
that people write about software testing.
So software testing is the
process of executing a programme
or application with the
intent of finding bugs
in the software.
It can also be described as the validation
and verification of a software
programme or application
or product or system.
That's not quite as
complicated as the definition
I came in.
But it's a lot of or's in there.
A lot of things we might be testing.
So if we simplify this,
we're executing something
to try to find bugs and
that can be described
as validation and verification.
Well they are big words,
I don't know necessarily
know off hand what validation
and verification is.
So I'm going to look that up.
So verification is the process
of establishing the truth,
accuracy or validity of something.
Okay we can call this
validation or verification.
And verification is
related to the validation
of something okay?
So validation is the act
of checking or proving
the validity of something...
So validation is validating something.
Definitions that are recursive like that
aren't particularly helpful.
So both of these seem to be quite similar,
they're self referential
and they're about the truth
or accuracy or proving.
I'm not going to use those words right?
So I have to find things out,
this is pretty what this is telling me
I have do stuff to find things out.
And clearly there's someone
makes a value judgement
on those things.
So that's what I'm doing.
So I'm gonna forget that
but I'm gonna generalise.
So software testing is doing stuff
to something to find out
stuff that I then tell people.
So stuff like bugs, what's wrong?
What's right?
'Cause we're trying to prove stuff,
that's what we got from
the other definition.
But we have to be careful
about certitudes and absolutes.
Find stuff that is wrong.
Find stuff that is right.
Software testing IS. Clearly
if we've got multiple
definitions, software testing
can be multiple things.
What we're working with are descriptions.
We have to be careful that
we've described software testing
and not prescribed software testing.
'Cause if this is software testing
this is all that I can do.
I might need to go beyond that.
But there is too much theory in there
and we can talk about theory forever.
We actually got work to do.
And we got to try to do this
work from first principles,
so let's figure that out.
So if I'm thinking what
is software testing?
I could instead think, what did they mean
when they asked me this?
Because they've used words
and words are communication.
And communication is a relationship.
So what did they mean?
And given my basic knowledge,
I can reflect that back to
people and look like I know
what I'm talking about.
So what you want me to do when you test?
You want me to find bugs?
You want me to verify this?
You want me to validate this?
How will I know it's a bug?
Is there anything specific
you want me to test it for?
And what do you want to do
with what I tell you right?
Things might change.
What is the end goal with
this thing that I give you?
Is the testing the
input to something else?
If so then I might be able
to adapt and give you that.
What do you mean?
Alright, we're throwing
this back at people.
So that's an important
technique in the sense that
we're giving somebody else the
responsibility for our job.
And if you do this enough times
eventually people will just
go ahhh too many questions.
Alright so here is what
I want you to do right?
I want you to focus on the
create author function,
so we got a system that
creates authors and books,
we're gonna focus on the
create author function,
make sure it handles a
range of input values.
Okay we're bluffing so,"What values?"
I don't know, good stuff,
No names, long names, bad
names, names, stuff right?
Then we've got if it creates
a user, we'll be fine right.
So we've done enough to just annoy them.
And we learned stakeholder
management, if we were going
to put
The kind of words that we use
to describe software testing
on what we just did,
we've learned stakeholder management.
Needs and requirement analysis.
Acceptance condition creation.
How will I know that this is correct?
Risk based testing,
what do you care about?
What do you want us to focus on?
Test scope restriction, by
using the risk, if I'm using
the functional scope that
we've been given to define it.
We also learned that we can ask questions
and people will give us answers
and there's nothing wrong with that.
Ideally we want to know
how to approach this
but under certain
circumstances we're gonna know
tactics, techniques. But
they're gonna know the scope
so we can ask them.
But I didn't ask,
why do you want me to do this?
So why didn't I ask, Why do
you want me to test this?
That's a rhetorical question.
It's partly rhetorical question
because this a recording
and you cannot answer me back.
But as soon as I say why do
you want me to test this?
If you think about that
and you try to answer it,
you're gonna come up with some answers.
But the reality is you don't know.
You don't know why I didn't ask that.
You don't know , you could guess.
You're building a model from nothing.
You making up assumptions
and you're working from your beliefs
and that's why I didn't ask why?
Why? is a belief chain question.
If I ask why do you want me to test this,
it's a chain of beliefs around testing.
Their relationship to testing.
Their relationship to me with testing.
It's a belief chain,
I'm not necessarily getting the scope.
I don't know how they're
going to answer that.
Alright, why do you want me to test this?
Because it's your job.
Because I don't want to test it.
Because testing sucks.
Because I want proof that it works right?
I don't know how they're
gonna interpret that question.
Because it's your job
that's their interpretation
in terms of relationship between me.
Because I don't want to test
it they're interpreting it
between their relationship and them.
Because testing sucks,
their relationship between
the concept of testing.
I want proof that works,
their relationship of
what they are going to do
with this information right?
I don't want the user
to find any problems,
their relationship of what is
going to happen in the future.
Each of these could be a how? or what?
when? or who? question.
If I ask why, they have to interpret it.
And sometimes they will
interpret based on beliefs.
And if it's beliefs, it can be a chain.
Now this might be useful 'cause
we could find the dynamics,
we can find out the power structures,
we can find out what
we need to teach people
if they misunderstanding things.
We don't have the same
understanding of certain concepts
that can come across when
we ask Why? questions.
We might even be able to
adopt different view points
to test in a different way,
all this can be useful.
But it might lead to a chain.
Why do you want me to test this?
Because it's your job.
Why is it my job?
Well because that's what we pay for?
Why do you pay me for this?
That's a good question,
'cause if you don't know what you're doing
perhaps we shouldn't,
perhaps we should find
someone even cheaper right?
You get into a belief chain
and your distancing
yourself from where that is.
Why you want me to test this?
'Cause I don't wanna test this.
Why you don't wanna test this?
I don't care why they don't want test it,
it's irrelevant to what we're doing.
But it's a belief chain process.
Five Whys is a belief chain process
and sometime it's more
effective to figure out
the path of questioning that we want.
And sometimes when we're
dealing with beliefs
you can get into conflict.
Because people take Why as a challenge,
if your challenge their beliefs
people try to defend them.
So I care about what they
believe but I care less
about what they believe
than more about their needs.
I wanna know what their needs are.
How their needs are?
When their needs are?
Where their needs are?
I can't do any imagineedfustication unless
I know about their needs.
So unless I know when they need them?
Unless I know what they need?
How they're gonna do that?
'Cause I'm an imagineedfusticator.
That's what I want to do.
So what do I do next?
Here's the application, go
back to the practicalities.
I need to create an author.
There's the dialogue
it says create author,
type in the author name
and hit the create button
and it creates an author.
So I'm going to plan it out a bit right?
So now I need no name now,
I just hit the button.
I need a good name.
Uh Bob the author seems like a good name,
there's probably better names.
I can pick real authors,
I can use their names.
And bad names, Mr. 123 no one has 123.
What's a bad name really?
Whose defining bad? Is
it in terms of naming?
Is it cultures, is it... I don't know?
What is appropriate in the system,
I don't know, bad is too non-specific.
I don't know how to do that.
But I'm gonna stick
with 123 at the moment.
So I hit the button
and it says please fill in this field.
So I can see that there is some validation
when I just hit save.
What are the rules?
I should check those right?
This is something I need to make a note of
and do later on.
'cause I've done my data value
but I don't know whether
that's good enough.
So I got questions I need to follow up on.
So when I do the good
name and create an author
and I say Bob the author,
it says we've added author Bob the author.
Great!
So my work is done or is it?
I mean isn't that is
what is suppose to do?
How, no one told me what it suppose to do.
I'm assuming that's what it suppose to do.
How do I know its the correct message,
added author Bob the author.
Is that correct?
I don't know.
Do I just decide this?
Is there some reference I can use?
And then I'm looking
and going wait a minute,
is that consistent?
'Cause it says create author
and I hit the create button.
And then it says we've added it.
Should it say created?
If it's added, where's added it?
What has it added it too?
Oh so many questions and we're
building up a model here.
Now what we've discovered to put it in
software testing terms
is the need for an oracle
a standard reference
something to guide us.
Conformance to some standard
requirements testing,
acceptance condition validation,
these are all valid things.
But we've also discovered exploration.
We came up with some ideas,
we tried them.
Our model got expanded,
we then have to revisit the plan
plan for more things.
And I don't think I got
enough bad stuff there,
I've haven't done bad stuff
yet, I've done good stuff.
Is it good enough?
Revisiting, we're learning as we go.
We also created a heuristic.
Look at us, how advanced are we.
Not only did we not start with 1970's,
1980's scripted testing.
We're way in the current forefront
of software testing knowledge,
we came up with a heuristic,
the consistency heuristic.
Is this application
consistent with itself?
consistent with other things?
The oracles, we are so cutting
edge when we're doing this.
But then I'm thinking,
well how do I tell people
what I've done?
I have to report back.
So I really better keep some
notes that will help me.
So I'm gonna start writing
down the questions,
what things I want to
test, what I need to know.
How I'm going to track all this?
I don't actually know
how people gonna do that.
So I'm gonna make it up.
I'm just gonna start making notes.
I'll put them in Evernote,
I'll create a list.
I'll do something
and I'll figure out
whether that's good enough.
How other people do this?
But we just discovered to
put it in testing terms,
exploratory testing.
The notion of: come up with an idea,
doing something,
learning from it,
planning something else.
Planning, test planning.
We're building out a test
plan for what we're gonna do
what we're gonna cover?
Why we're gonna do that?
What needs are we gonna
meet as we do them?
What tools do we need?
What tools do I need in order
to help me do this work?
I'm in a browser?
I need a tool to make notes.
We're thinking about reporting our work,
don't know quite how
we're gonna do that yet
but we'll adjust it and refine over time.
Now the application said
the author was added,
but did it?
Now how can I see that?
I need to be able to see that.
I need to be able to
interrogate the system
to see that its done what it said it did.
So I'm gonna look in the list of authors
and it says it's there.
But can I trust that?
Is that good enough?
Now I can see that there's
more functionality.
I can amend authors,
I assume that x is a deletion.
I can do stuff,
ones a link, ones a button.
What's going on... is that OK?
I don't know!
But I'm learning more stuff.
I'm using the application to test itself,
but I don't know if I can trust that.
I'm not observing at a low enough level.
I don't know how the data is stored.
I don't know exactly what data is stored.
I don't know when it stored?
Where it stored?
I don't know how I can
see this stored data.
Now all of this is simple questioning
but it's based around me,
I need the feedback
that things are working.
I need the ability to check that things
are happening the way they expect.
I need the ability to manipulate it
and look at it more detail.
So we've actually just
discovered an important
characteristic about
testing which is doubt.
How do I know?
I haven't got the
evidence to back this up.
So I doubt what I'm seeing.
I need to go in in more detail.
But I need to figure out a level
at which to stop for that.
And the fundamental testing technique
that's coming across here
is the art of questioning.
Asking appropriate questions
to get the information we need.
I also discovered essentially
some graph based testing.
I created a thing,
I looked in the application
to see the information
so I got create/read flow.
I'm starting to do create,
read, update, delete
'cause I saw the amend, I saw the delete.
I've got a concept, a
model here that I can apply
to testing to guide me with my coverage.
So we ask these questions
and someone answers it
and then right our model
just explodes right?
Because the validation
rules are controlled by HTML
using HTML5 using the required
and pattern attributes.
When the create button is
pressed an HTTP POST request
the server, ahhh so much stuff.
Now some of you are gonna
read that and understand it.
Some of you are gonna read that and go
I don't understand that technology.
So in order to really
understand this and test it,
we might have to look up this technology.
We might have to understand that.
But they can see that we're
confused so they create
a diagram to help us and
they walk it through.
Now we got visual representation,
I can see paths there.
I can see there's a server involved.
I need to put things
through into the server
and that sometimes the
server will do validation.
But I got stuff I need to learn now
'cause we are continually
expanding our model
and that's good.
We expect this.
But it's constant learning.
So I know the concept of HTML,
how do I see that?
So you show me the Dev tools.
And then not just I see concept of HTML,
I can see these attributes
but I can see there's
elements H2, DIV I mean
I can kinda map them up and
make guesses H2 is bigger
than a form which is bigger
than just normal text.
But I'm kinda drawing conclusions,
I need to do more research.
But it's interesting that I can see it.
Oh my God!
Right, I can change it to.
I can edit and delete
that required attribute
I'm changing the system.
Am I hacking?
What is happening?
How far can I go with
this so I can change it?
So if I know the validation is done by
the required attribute and I delete it.
What if there's no validation?
I got rid of the validation.
So when I hit enter it says,
could not find the name to add.
So I know that there is
server side validation now.
But now I have to test
the server side validation
and the front end validation.
It's gonna take me quite a
lot of time to amend the form
every time I come in and I want
to do server side validation
so that we can test the
HTTP level then right?
'Cause HTTP traffic is sent,
that's what they're telling me,
I don't know this.
I've just made a statement,
it's good enough,
I have a problem,
and then somebody is explaining
things in more detail.
So they tell me about HTTP Debug Proxy
where I do something on the front end,
the message get sent through a proxy.
But now I can work at a proxy level,
I can work at the HTTP level,
this is a whole new world.
There's a whole new set
of information in there
that I have to learn my
world is just expanding.
And getting ever more technical
but it's getting technical
because I need to do it
in order to solve certain problems
with the work that I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to test more
easily and I can do that here.
So I ask questions like
how does this work?
What does this do?
How can I see that?
How can I make that happen?
What should it do?
I didn't ask any why? questions,
these are very specific questions
which got me very specific answers.
How? When? Where?
That is what is important
and knowing how to ask those
questions to drill down
gets us places faster.
Why? might get me there.
But it might be a twist and turn
and I might ask different people
and get different answers.
Now, the interesting thing for me is,
this doesn't seem that hard right?
We're asking questions
but for some people this
is a hard thing to do
because people don't like to be seen as
not knowing something, possibly.
And I say why people find this tough,
I don't know,
I'm making this up.
My beliefs about why other
people find this hard are
you're reasons why this is hard
for you might be different.
You're beliefs about other
people find this hard
might be different this
is what I'm assuming.
It seems as though when I look online
people don't like to say I don't know.
They don't like to say that.
I don't know why right?
People don't get in the
habit of saying I don't know,
they bluff it out.
Maybe they're concerned that their beliefs
don't go far enough and they
don't want to be exposed.
Or maybe their belief is not
set on any rock foundation
and if someone quizzes it, it collapses
and it got void and that's
bad so they don't know.
So what I'm thinking in terms of it,
what could these things be? right?
Where is questioning is involved right?
We got notions of scientist,
skeptics, believers
and seekers.
Scientist, I'm gonna give you
my interpretation of this,
they not necessarily
dictionary definitions.
But scientists for me is
someone who is working from
a belief model of the world
that's backed up by evidence
that's reinforced by other
evidence from other scientist.
And there's an agreed model of the world
that people work with.
Scientist tends to explore
that or just edge slightly
outside that belief model
but pretty much they're exploring
an existing belief model
and trying to expand it
and check that it continues
to hold up under close scrutiny.
To really go deep into it.
To build the best and most
accurate model they can
of the world.
Believers.
Let's jump to believers.
Believers, believe stuff.
Almost regardless of evidence right?
It doesn't matter if there's,
it almost doesn't matter
if there's evidence or not.
'Cause it's for them an internal thing.
They believe in ... the earth is flat
because other people have said it's flat.
And it caused them,
some say well I mean if it was round,
how could it be round right?
People in Australia would fall off,
how could it possibly be that?
It has to be flat, common sense.
Look at your table, you
drop something off the edge
it falls down.
People in Australia and it's
round they would fall off.
Common sense right?
So people believe stuff 'cause we can.
If it's something outside
our realm of checking things,
we have to believe people.
We believe scientists.
We believe scientists
and what they tell us
because they done the experiments
and they have the authority.
Skeptics tend to straddle the ground
between scientist and believers.
Scientist don't have time to
deal with pseudo scientists
who believe stuff that
is outside their model.
Skeptics tend to bridge that gap.
So they will have the scientific model
they will ask questions of a believer
then they will take that on board
quiz them and they go nah
you're talking nonsense.
But the skeptic has that
I will approach over
into the world of a believer.
Then we come into the Seeker.
Now the Seeker is different.
The Seeker is all of these things.
Scientist are Seekers when
they go outside their models
we seek out new things to learn
but the seeker has the
ability to take on beliefs
and discard them later
but when they take them
on they believe them,
they inhabit them they
explore the world as though
those belief existed.
And testers, that's
really important right.
Now Ken Campbell was a seeker.
Ken Campbell, talked about this a lot
he was an almost a improvisational actor.
He's a very different acting style.
He taught people how to
act and explore things.
And I he would even be saying things like
"well just supposing".
Just supposing Fairies did exist.
And the seeker would then take
that belief fairies exist.
Where would fairy exist?
If you go out and look in those places.
How would I see them if they did exist?
How would I know they were there?
And that's different from believing
and it's slightly different from scientist
because we're exploring beliefs
which are clearly not
scientific and not within any
frame of belief.
But that belief itself,
adopting that belief
gives you a different attitude.
Gives you a different way
of exploring the world.
You look at things differently.
You will observe things differently.
You will try and
manipulate different things
that might otherwise be there.
Now if projects don't have seekers,
projects don't have people
trying to go outside
the bounds of beliefs of that project.
We're not going to find
the really hard problems
that only occur once in awhile.
The edge cases that exist on the periphery
of our beliefs systems.
Seekers are really important.
Robert Anton Wilson someone else
I particularly enjoy his
books who is also dead.
Hopefully this is not a common paradigm.
Robert Anton Wilson said belief
is the death of intelligence
as soon as one believes
a doctrine of any sort
or assumes certitude,
ones stops thinking about
that aspect of existence.
Now the danger of this
if I believe that quote.
(laughs)
If I believe that belief
is death of intelligence
I might stop thinking about that aspect.
But that's okay 'cause I'm a seeker.
So I can take that belief,
adopt it and discard it right?
Seekers have the ability
to take on beliefs,
take on different personas.
Believe that the system
will function under
high performance loads we'll focus on
somewhere else.
Believe that it won't
and really hit it hard.
Believe that it will handle performance
but not when certain things are going on.
We will seek out alternative
beliefs in order to adopt them.
Now given that people
have difficulty with this.
I'm gonna give you some
tactics just in case,
just in case you don't know
or if you think not knowing
is bad or anything like that.
So this is the summary of it,
knowing nothing is good
and you don't actually
know nothing about it.
Are they contradictory?
Possibly.
Don't care, I'm a seeker.
I can have multiple
beliefs at the same time.
And we ask questions when we know stuff.
So I know nothing about
Kardashians, Big Brother
all that kind of stuff,
reality t.v. and that is good.
I would defend the notion that is good,
very hard.
'Cause that is a belief but
I know nothing about it,
I'm comfortable with that.
That you can just get comfortable knowing
nothing about it is a decision I have made
to know nothing about it.
But the reality is right?
I don't know nothing about it.
I clearly know something,
I know their name right?
Its just that the things I know about it
I've described as nothing right?
Like some of the words that we have
the definitions we have
they're descriptive,
they're not prescriptive.
And my not knowing about
Kardashians doesn't mean
that I know nothing about them.
It's just describing a lack of something
it's as good as nothing.
So when we're in this position,
what we have is a model that can expand.
Its not that I know nothing,
it's that I have a model
I describe as nothing.
So I can ask questions and
see if nothing fits that.
Do I know nothing about Kardashians,
there some women some men there I think.
There's,
I know some stuff right?
By I try to expand my
model if I care. right?
I try to invalidate parts
to my model if I care.
Same as normal when we're
working with any model.
It's not that I know nothing
its that I described it as nothing.
And our descriptions are not prescriptive.
They're attempting to
build a model of something.
Now when I'm a manager
and I'm working in teams
I'm a consultant and I work in teams.
I ask questions even when I do know stuff.
'Cause I don't mind if other
people think I don't know stuff
because I'll say something later on
that will boost my credibility again.
But I also know that other
people in the room don't know.
And people have difficulty
saying I don't know.
So if I say I don't know
then they will learn.
I know that people have
different understandings right?
Because the words are
reused in different places
so people hear word, we're
gonna do a performance test,
oh yes, oh yes.
But they have completely different models.
One person its speed, one person
its load. Different models.
so they go away with
the wrong understanding
so I can go, what? I don't
understand what is performance
testing? and what do you
mean by performance testing?
Then we will gain more of
a shared understanding.
Sometimes it gives someone a
chance to share their knowledge
by not asking a question,
you are not giving someone
who wouldn't speak up
the opportunity to show their knowledge
and develop their skills of communication
in a certain environment.
And that's important when
you're developing your staff
asking questions that they can answer.
Boosts their confidence
and their credibility
and their independence
of credibility from you.
They gain independent
credibility as an expert.
'Cause asking questions
fundamentally is a good thing to do.
And that's what testers do.
Testers are seekers.
Testers bring in the
attributes of the scientist,
the sceptic, the believer
all in one in the seeker
'cause we can take on beliefs
and we can see the value
in doing something even
when no one else does.
And we can drop that belief
and bring in another one.
Seekers is what we're attempting to do
because fundamentally
asking questions is good
and it's how we explore the world.
And build up models from
nothing, or what we describe as nothing
which is
common sense.